In this segment of the class.
What I would like to do is take a look at the sort of geography of the death
penalty and most importantly,
the historical factors that led to that.
Uh,
there's a lot of information about the death pony available,
uh,
on the,
website of the death penalty information center,
which www death penalty info.org g,
uh,
I would refer you to that for things like which states have the death penalty,
which states don't,
uh,
how many people are on death row in each state,
how many executions.
All of that sort of information is collected there.
Uh,
there's also evidence,
uh,
or excuse me,
information about,
uh,
some of what we will be talking about over the course@asecondclassjustice.com.
Uh,
but I just want to mention a couple of things.
first to look at executions by regions.
Uh,
in the United States is,
we can see,
and this is since 1976 as I said,
the death penny was declared unconstitutional by the Supreme Court in 1972 in
the case of Furman versus Georgia 1976,
the supreme court upheld the death penalty,
at least have some states.
Uh,
and so we really measure the modern death Polly by what's happened,
uh,
since 1976 under the new statutes that we'll be talking about in the next
session.
Um,
uh,
since that time,
this is from 1976 until the end of 2012.
Uh,
so you can see over a thousand executions in the south,
uh,
only 155 in the Midwest,
82 in the west and only for a in the northeast.
Uh,
if we look at the states that have carried out over 50 executions to since 1976,
we see Texas,
uh,
by far in a way,
almost 500.
At the end of 2012,
only two other states,
over a hundred Virginia in Oklahoma.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
other states,
that have,
uh,
are above Georgia 50 to Alabama and 55 Missouri.
Uh,
it's 68 in Florida.
It's 74,
uh,
that are above that level.
Uh,
this is an interesting way to look at how the death penalty is imposed in the
United States.
This is less than 1% of all the counties in the United States.
In fact,
it's less than 1% of the counties in states that have the death penalty.
I mean,
here's another way to look at it.
All of the counties in red are Texas counties.
Uh,
and you see out of the top 10,
only Oklahoma City and Saint Louis County,
Missouri,
uh,
are,
are in the highest number of counties.
Uh,
and then when we get to the last five,
we do have counties of Arizona,
Ohio,
Alabama to Alabama counties there.
Well,
what,
what's the reason for the fact that so many of these executions are in the south
that our largest death rows or in the south?
Uh,
well,
uh,
part of the reason is slavery.
Uh,
the,
uh,
fact of the matter was,
the time of slavery in this country.
The southern states had to deal with the captive population.
There was always a threat of some sort of slavers revolt or organizing of
slaves.
Uh,
in three of the southern states,
there were actually more Africans in slavery than there were white people.
So it was a very delicate,
uh,
situation in terms of a controlling these people.
And as a result,
uh,
a number of,
death polling provisions applied to slaves and even freed slaves,
many capital statutes,
uh,
applied,
only two blacks,
uh,
whether slaves or free.
Uh,
and,
uh,
of course,
in colonial times when the country first started,
uh,
we didn't have any prisons.
Uh,
the only way you punish people was by killing them,
uh,
cutting off their fingers,
branding them,
a whipping them,
which was a,
a punishment at that time,
putting people in stocks.
Uh,
any of those punishments today would seem pretty primitive.
but the one that we still have,
uh,
is the death pony a lot.
We will see in the northern states,
uh,
once prisons became available,
the great decline in the use of the death Poli.
Uh,
but that was not the case in the south.
And the reason for that,
uh,
was,
slavery.
Uh,
what the northern states did was move away from the death pony.
In fact,
uh,
even before the civil war,
Michigan in 1946,
uh,
later Rhode Island and Wisconsin abolish the death penalty altogether.
But in the other northern states,
the death penalty was increasingly limited only to murder cases,
homicide cases,
uh,
whereas in the south,
although the legislature's did away with the death pony for some crimes against,
uh,
it's because,
crimes committed by whites.
Uh,
it was still used for all sorts of crimes against black people because it was
seen as in dispensable to managing 2 million people who were in slavery.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
even distributing leaflets was a capital crime and Louisiana,
as well as all sorts of other crimes like burglary,
larceny,
robbery,
rape,
of course,
was a,
it was a capital crime and many people were,
uh,
either lynched or sentenced to death for,
for lynching.
So that resulted in the end of the war comes and,
uh,
the southern states still have capital punishment and it becomes even more
important perhaps,
uh,
after,
the war,
uh,
the Supreme Court that's keeps me,
the Congress passed the 14th amendment to the United States constitution,
providing that no state would co denying any person the equal protection of the
law.
This is adopted in 1868.
Uh,
and the hope of this was that the free blacks in the south would be protected by
federal enforcement under the equal protection clause.
And that the state would,
is a no state shall deny any person the equal protection of the law.
However,
that didn't really last too long.
Uh,
not long afterwards.
The Colfax massacre in Louisiana where a group of black people who have been
deputized were holed up in the court house.
Uh,
they were attacked by whites.
A number of the blacks were killed.
Uh,
very few people were prosecuted.
But one of the prosecution's made its way to the Supreme Court of the United
States.
Uh,
and the court said,
you can't prosecute this because the amendment says no state.
Well,
the people who attacked the courthouse,
we're not the state.
It was a mob,
a Klu Klux Klan.
Uh,
basically.
and so the clause was interpreted in a way that actually protected the Klu Klux
Klan,
uh,
rather than holding the local officials responsible for not having a,
enforced the law and protected the people at the courthouse.
But the case that really caused the most damage was one that came a little
later.
United States versus,
uh,
Reece,
which involves some people in Kentucky who were refusing to register black
people to vote,
uh,
and they were prosecuted for that.
And the Supreme Court,
United States versus Reese,
uh,
said,
when do you not only have to show that they intended to do that,
but that their motive was race.
Now this is a very difficult thing to prove in all criminal prosecutions.
Generally you prove intent that a person intended the national natural and
probable consequences of their action,
but proving why someone acted,
did they act for racial reasons.
This,
as we will see all the way through the course,
uh,
becomes a tremendous hurdle to enforcing a,
or preventing racial discrimination from taking place,
uh,
in the criminal courts,
um,
after,
uh,
the civil war.
Of course,
a lynching,
uh,
terrorism,
became,
uh,
quite common as a way to preserve white supremacy as a way to keep the newly
freed slaves.
And pretty much the,
uh,
the bondage that,
that they had been in,
uh,
this,
phenomenon and the fact that it happens so much inspired,
uh,
Billie holiday,
to,
uh,
perform this song.
Strange fruit.
Yes.
Yeah.
Black body swinging.
Ooh.
In the summer.
Strange food.
Hang in.
Ron Pastors scene.
MMM.
Jean
missed it.
Set up men.
No.
Yeah.
Sweet.
Huh?
He's a fruit.
Oh,
the curl.
Well,
yeah.
Oh,
no way.
Ah,
Bra
two.
John [inaudible]
Niche,
correct.
Ah,
strain fruit was written by,
uh,
Abel Marpol under the name Louis Allen.
Uh,
Billie holiday performing this song brought a lot of attention.
to lynching,
uh,
as did the work of Ida B wells and the Naacp,
as this was happening so frequently,
uh,
during this time period,
strange fruit actually made it to the 16th place on the charts,
uh,
in music in 1939.
Uh,
this is a execution or this,
uh,
hanging of a Reuben Stacey,
in Florida.
And I just offered to show the little girls dressed up in their Sunday best who
are here,
uh,
watching,
this lynching in Fort Lauderdale,
Florida.
Uh,
in 1935,
uh,
often lynchings were,
somewhat of a carnival type event where the families coming,
people bring in picnics and all of those sorts of things.
A lot of the leading citizens,
uh,
there,
but almost no prosecutions.
Almost every report of a lynching would say,
uh,
that it was conducted,
at the hands of a party's unknown.
Uh,
even though it had all been public and everybody knew exactly who had had,
had been participating.
This is launching here is of um,
um,
uh,
Jesse Washington and Waco,
Texas,
15,000 people were there for it,
uh,
in the readings that accompany the classes.
A lot more information both about lynching and about the efforts to end it by
Ida B wells and the Naacp and,
and others.
And some statistics about it,
uh,
from the Tuskegee Institute,
which,
which started monitoring,
uh,
lynchings.
Uh,
the point worth mentioning here is that Congress never passed an anti-lynching
act.
Uh,
even when President Truman asked for it,
a congress didn't pass an anti lynching act even though there's terrorism was
going on.
And you look today when we pass terrorism hacks without a great deal of thought
going into them,
perhaps,
uh,
over and over again,
it was,
uh,
efforts were made to pass anti-lynching laws.
Uh,
but the southern senators led by Richard Russell of Georgia,
uh,
would always oppose them,
and all its opposed them under the guise of the constitution.
Federalism states rights.
A lot of the arguments that we're going to hear all through the course with
regard to,
uh,
the role of the federal government's.
In reviewing a capital cases and so forth.
Uh,
these two lawyers are worth mentioning as people who stand out in the history of
this troubled time.
Uh,
Noah partner and styles.
Hutchins,
uh,
Ed Johnson was,
convicted of a crime of rape and Chattanooga,
Tennessee.
These two African American lawyers had somehow managed to have a successful law
practice in Chattanooga,
Tennessee at the turn of the century,
around 1900.
Uh,
somehow they were,
uh,
succeeding in that.
Uh,
ed Johnson's father comes and talks to Noah parden about taking the case of Ed
Johnson.
Uh,
he goes to his partner styles.
Hutchins.
They have to know that if they take this case,
nothing is ever going to be the same again.
And yet styles Hutchson says,
uh,
to us much it's been given and much is required.
They take the case,
no pardon goes to Washington,
argues before Justice Harlan obtains a stay of execution.
A mob that night breaks into the jail,
takes that Johnson out,
hangs him over the bridge there in Chattanooga,
the river that goes through town riddled with bullets.
Uh,
and just a short time after that,
uh,
Noah parden in styles,
Hutchins had to close their law practice and leave Chattanooga and neither ever
came back again.
Uh,
I would come into your book by,
uh,
Leroy Phillips and Mark Cureton,
a contempt of court,
which describes this case and the historic work of these two lawyers who long
forgotten,
but who really,
uh,
answered the call,
to stand up for justice in this particular case at enormous cost to them.
Uh,
personally.
Um,
the next part a and an a coming this time of lynching was convict leasing.
I recommend a couple of books on this to really get an in depth a sense of how
pervasive convict leasing was.
Two books here,
slavery by another name,
uh,
and worse than slavery,
a worse than slavery is by David Oshinsky and slavery by another name by Douglas
Blackmon,
uh,
which won the Pulitzer Prize.
There's also a website,
uh,
for slavery by another name,
which has a great deal of information in it.
And,
and I would recommend it,
uh,
this is about the practice that the criminal courts were engaged in,
after the civil war of leasing prisoners,
almost all black prisoners,
uh,
leasing them to the plantations and the Turpentine camps and the railroads and
the coal mines around Birmingham,
Alabama,
uh,
to,
to do labor.
And the reason it was worse than slavery is because when people had slaves,
they at least had some interest in their property.
Uh,
the slave is property.
But when you had convicts,
you literally had people who are disposable,
you could send the convicts in the mind and if the mine collapsed and killed
them all,
it just simply a went to the sheriff and got some more.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this,
very brutal practice went on right up until the 1940s,
after,
uh,
up until World War Two,
in Alabama,
uh,
convicts were moved from job to job and rolling cages.
And not only was this the way they were moved from job to job,
this was also their housing.
This was in Pitt County,
North Carolina in,
um,
uh,
1910.
Uh,
this is the living quarters of a convict's working in coal mines near
Birmingham,
Alabama.
Uh,
as David was Chenowski says,
uh,
in his book,
a convict leasing was designed for black,
not white convicts.
It was possible to send a Negro to prison on almost any pretext,
but is very difficult to get a white person there unless they had committed a
very heinous crime.
The law allowed whites to exploit blacks without legal limit to withhold the
most basic rights and safeguards while claiming to be indulgent.
A paternalistic,
uh,
in fair,
worse,
it turned the criminal justice system into a corrupt and capricious entity,
utterly undeserving of respect.
I mean,
this is the criminal justice system.
Uh,
during,
uh,
the 20th century,
Dan Carter points out,
uh,
in his book about Scottsboro,
that southerners discovered that lynching,
uh,
finally discovered the lynchings were untidy and created a bad press.
Uh,
and they were increasingly replaced,
uh,
by situations in which the southern legal system,
a prostituted itself to what the mob demanded basically would be.
Lynchers would just be told,
let the law take its course.
In the understanding there of course was that the people would be arrested or
they'd give them a quick trial.
We're just perfunctory representation before an all male,
all white jury,
and they'd be sentenced to death.
And promptly,
uh,
executed as he says,
such proceedings,
uh,
had all the essence a of a mob violence,
shedding only it's most outward form,
the outright violence that that happened in the situation.
Uh,
this is the Scottsboro boys,
the power versus Alabama landmark Supreme Court case about the right to counsel
for people facing the death penalty.
Uh,
these young men were tried in Scottsboro Alabama in 1931 and the people at
Scottsboro actually thought that they had done something positive here.
They didn't Lynch these young men who were charged with the rape of two white
women.
Instead,
they gave him a trial.
Now,
much of a trial,
uh,
trials that,
started only a very short time,
uh,
after the crime.
Uh,
that went very fast.
There were dominated by mobs outside and inside the courthouse.
Uh,
but trials nonetheless.
and many people said,
you know,
if this had happened few years ago,
we would have just lynched these young men.
So why isn't everybody satisfied?
Well,
of course,
the answer being that the trials were a sham,
uh,
and,
the national guard was there throughout the entire time protecting these young
men.
Uh,
you can see the national guard behind the young men in this picture.
Um,
and,
uh,
but the supreme court record didn't have a great deal about the mobs outside of
the courtroom.
Didn't have a great deal of some about the national guard because it's mentioned
in the opinion.
But what the court seized on was the appointment of the lawyers in the case that
basically on the morning of trial,
there was no lawyer.
A judge had earlier appointed all of the members of the bar,
uh,
to the case.
And they all found some reason to get out of it,
except for one,
my low moody,
who was an elderly Sorta dottering,
uh,
lawyers somewhat senile according to Dan Carter's book on Scottsboro.
Uh,
and then Steve Roddy,
a lawyer who came from Chattanooga at the behest of the families of some of
these people.
But,
uh,
as Carter also says,
who fortified himself with alcohol,
uh,
before dealing with a very unhappy,
are very hostile to him,
uh,
audience in the courtroom.
Uh,
and they basically decide on the morning of trial that they're going to try the
case and they try the cases in a series of trials in which the death penalty is
imposed.
The first jury goes out,
it comes back with a death sentence.
The second jury is hearing a case and it hears the roar from the crowd.
Uh,
when the death penalty is imposed,
uh,
the court says that,
lawyers are necessary from the outset for a thorough going investigation of the
case.
And then in a capital case,
lawyers must be provided.
We'll see that lawyers are not provided another,
uh,
serious criminal cases in the states until 1963.
Um,
finally I want to introduce,
uh,
Gilbert king who came,
as a guest to class and to talk about,
uh,
Jim Crow Justice and to talk about Thurgood Marshall's role.
Uh,
in one particular case,
a number of African Americans who were facing the death penalty in Groveland,
Florida,
and the 1940s,
late 1940s,
uh,
he does a marvelous job telling the story,
in this book.
This was much like the Scottsburg case.
Uh,
it was for young African American men,
two of them ultimately killed by the sheriff,
uh,
or as Posse,
but who were charged with rape of a white woman.
Uh,
he is also the author of a book on the execution of Willie Francis,
a man who was at least Louisiana,
tried to execute in one time and he was not killed,
uh,
went to the Supreme Court,
which allowed,
uh,
Louisiana try a second time and the second time Willie Francis was executed.
Uh,
but we're very fortunate to have Gilbert king join us for our class,
uh,
and to tell us some about his research and what went into the book.
A devil in the grove about Thurgood Marshall and the Groveland boys.
Okay.